okay well my wife my wife took the
shahadat she immediately decided to put
his job on her on her and to change her
clothes and everything and even I asked
her are you really sure about this
because if you are not sure she told me
yes I am sure and I want I want to put
his job and even now four years after
most of the people who knows me who
knows her even who don't know us they
think that I told her to pull the job it
wasn't it was just her decision she
wanted to put his job because she want
to serve to God and she wanted to do
this you know and it was not my decision
even now I'm always thinking it's not
the bad people
ah you are so tough guy you probably
dominate with her and tell her to put no
it's not my choice it was her choice can
you see the birds they flying that
nothing keep them in the sky that only
God keep them up school down I don't
want to tell everything about this keep
on with the Dean show
[Music]
ladies a piece assalamualaikum guys how
you doing we're at the life-changing
factory and you're gonna find out why
we're here with Nadine Bobby assalamu
alaikum wa rahmatullahu the cattle how
are you brother
al hamdulillah you have a beautiful
facility here inside I vote is the
capital of Bosnia and he started with
that greeting of peace peace be with you
so it says well let's start with that
why why your motto is life changing
Factory
so tell us a little bit about that ok
regarding my trainings and my system
during I work on functional workouts but
my my philosophy life change in fact
it's not about only about training your
body I like to change the philosophy of
mind with the people you know that start
living the the training you know this is
the one of the one of the reason why is
the life changing factory one of the
biggest killers is the ego and you
actually have on your wall a list of
points and what's the number one point
that's in there the number one points to
leave your ego outside of my dream the
point of that is it's not important how
much or how much money you have are you
poor are you rich what kind what kind
University you finish or something it's
important just you came in my dream to
Train
this is the one of the one of the reason
why is they leave the ego outside
outside of the gym yeah now not only are
you a successful business entrepreneur
with probably the most successful gym in
the probably in the Balkans
you know this whole area but you're also
someone who's dedicated to your Dean how
long ago did you start reflecting about
the purpose of life and living your
purpose
alhamdulillah I started thinking okay I
grew up in in people who lives here know
that we grew up in very mixed
environment and I start thinking about
this when I was 18 maybe 18 19 and I'm
practicing the alhamdulillah
the salaah and everything already
probably 20 years I'm 38 years old and
you can get I will say out of the road
but you have to always come back to your
God to Allah and everything will be good
because and some other things that I
always using it's can I see some I yes
absolutely yes yeah III like surah Mook
it's I know how to say in English its
power or something like that there's the
one at the turning away military Falcons
fatty wire cabinet my MC Cunha in Lara
ha man in a hooby coalition ambassador I
will try on English that like can you
see the birds they flying that nothing
keep them in the sky that only God keep
them up so I I try to to act like this
you know I'm working and everything but
I always put my back on the and on Allah
alhamdulillah this is giving me a lot of
power and I have one sentence when I see
what I see the other people cannot even
imagine because I know that that when
you believe in Allah everything is
possible
that's right when you believe in the
Creator anything is possible you also
have a unique story with your wife she
comes from a background Russian Orthodox
Christian share that story with us
please this is the very interesting
story I think my wife she's Orthodox
Russian she grew up in San Juanico
she grew up grow up on north of Russia
it's a name of cities are hangers it's a
north I think that they ever saw any
kind of Muslim or did even it's now 2019
and they just got first mosque there
ever so she moved here as Orthodox and
married me six years ago
and the first two years of marriage she
was always asking me some question about
Islam and I was giving her some answers
and she tried to have of course I told
her that in my house is Islam and my
group my children will grow up as a
Muslims and everything shy she accepted
this and I told her I don't I don't have
anything against your religion like like
cool I think
continued kumoi leading your region to
you my religion to my me but day by day
she was listening some lectures giving
me some questions and one time she after
two years she asked me can she go to
visit her mother in our hangars in
Russia and and of course she went over
there after one month she came back and
she told me I want to convert to Islam I
wanted to Sheridan
the point is that when I asked her of
course I mean me as a Muslim who born as
a Muslim here in Bosnian sorry oh it was
very interesting even for me why did you
do it this because I I never put any
kind of force like in Quran it's written
there's no force in religion I never put
she told me everything is clear because
you have answers for every every
question in Orthodox I could not find a
answer for everything
and she told me when I was in in Russia
I told to myself I want to go in Russia
again
to try to not think about Allah do not
think about creation and everything but
whatever I saw tree or grass or never
say I was Allah made this so beautiful
and she told me when I was in a plane
flying I was thinking I know all true
but I didn't took she had it and I was
scared so she came here and hamdullah
last he took Shahada it was Ramadan and
by now alhamdulillah she is praying five
times per day she is a hamdulillah on on
good way together
we are here that's one of the things
when a human being is reflecting
pondering and they want to know the
truth that is the first thing that one
has to decide are they gonna be just
seeking the worldly pleasures but she
was a thinking woman and she started to
think and Islam provides all the
rational logic logical evidences that it
is indeed from the creator of the
heavens and earth there is one myth that
we are already a couple in here because
she's a woman and one of the myths out
there is that Islam oppresses subjugates
woman it was on her free choice she was
a thinking woman yes so she again this
is this is an intelligent intellectual
decision she made she looked at the
evidences
everything's clear the worship of the
Creator not the creation the Quran
putting it to the test and then from
there we already cleared one myth that
there's more women actually coming to
Islam now the third thing is here
especially in this region we see that a
lot of people even from the Serbian
Croatian background they're coming to
Islam but many people think like how can
you be Muslim if you're Serbian how
could you be Muslim in in Croatian let's
dispel that myth now I will be honest
with you I think that is not only for
Muslim in Bosnia and this area I think
they're people who born in Islam I'm
seeing like from the parents who are
Muslims they always thinking that Islam
is their private thing you know that
like that nobody can be Muslim if he's
not born in Islam if he's not born by
Muslim parents and the point is when the
it was happened even even similar with
my wife when she converted to Islam
alhamdulillah and when she when she put
hijab and everything everybody was
thinking he force her on this and
honestly it was true why I didn't want
and anytime to argument about this
because the God knows the best and that
the point is that Islam is the for all
people all kind so it's not priority if
God want to give you on right way he
will give you if want to left you in the
bad way you left you so the the Islam is
like this so if you want to come in
Islam and creator one to put you in the
right way he will put it beautiful so we
covered some gems here Islam unifying
Croatian Serbians Bosnians Russians
anyone who wants to submit their will to
the creator of the heavens and earth
live a purposeful life you can find all
those answers in this beautiful way of
life Islam and if you want to go ahead
and get a great workout and join the the
factory gym champion Jim champion
champion factor life-changing factory
they can come and visit you here where
can they come see you we have website
you can check all information on our
website Jim champion Dada thank you very
much for visiting me here with your
friends I'm very honored for thank you
thank you big thank al hamdulillah
may Allah bless you I mean and thank you
guys for tuning in here from Bosnia
Sarah peace be with you
assalamualaikum shaikh wa rahmatullahi
Brocato